lie smear slander character
assassination besmirch
it's all coming this defines them and
then the threats
we're going to pack the court we're
going to get rid of the electoral
college we'll impeach the president
every day
this is now the party of anarchy to me
sarah sanders
president trump hasn't even named who he
will nominate to the supreme court
and they have already started
aggressively and viciously attacking
judge barrett one of the potential
nominees
a very conservative strong woman they
are attacking her for her christian
faith let's not forget these are the
same
liberals who lecture us about empowering
women
when the truth is they're nothing but
liars and hypocrites who are only trying
to empower themselves
and their radical agenda this is a time
for us to send a clear
and strong message that we will not
tolerate the liberal mob
president trump will stand up to them
and he has the support of the american
people
and the party to do that with him and
we're going to fix the court and fill
the seat
he absolutely has a constitutional
obligation to do it
and he should and he has to stand up and
continue fighting
against this radical left liberal mob
that thinks that they get to control and
run our country when they don't
if they try to eliminate the electoral
college and they're threatening court
packing and they're threatening to
impeach the president every day
haven't they just thrown down with the
mob
that's what they've become they have
been completely and totally
owned by the radical left let's not for
a minute think that joe biden
if he somehow manages to win will be
running
anything he will be completely and
totally controlled by the liberal left
and the radical mob
look who they trotted out front and
center to be one of the first people
to respond and come out it was aoc she
will be
just as much in control as anyone else
and i think that should be terrifying
for
every american and certainly for every
woman
conservative women need to stand up and
fight back
as much as anybody because they
certainly won't be empowering you
they'll be trying to tear you down
every chance they get